the real issue is the dire poverty of
much of the world and what we can do
about it and a current a debate has two
poles one poll says well the real answer
in the West is we need to spend some
certain fraction of GDP per targets
maybe point seven percent on aid to me
as an economist that pole is always some
odd we typically measure success or
failure not how much you spend on the
other end or well-meaning people who say
you know look the past 40 years of a bit
of failure and they're largely correct
and supporters they're talking about
economic aid so let's stop doing it I
don't think that's the right Laurel
answer and I certainly don't think it's
the right pick and i'm a cancer we can
do this
short and the ideas really in two steps
first is to step back and say what works
and if you look at economies that have
become prosperous whether it's
historically or in the modern period
it's about invigorating the local
business center that's how the United
States got rich that's how the West got
rich that's how modern growth miracles
in Asia and even in parts of Africa have
happened one of the things we could do
there is to focus much more economic aid
on local business in there in the book
the a trap I argued that we should go to
the software for Marshall Plan people
think of the marshall plan for europe
and 1947 252 is being a grand aid scheme
it wasn't that at all the Marshall Plan
loan money to local businesses it was
only when that money got paid back that
it went to governments and the entire
plan was run by business people Europe
then is not the same as African now but
that same software could work
we first start with the big picture of
institutional reform President Bush
implemented what was called the
Millennium Challenge account which was a
very good idea trying to condition USA
on institutional reforms that are
pro-business we need to keep that but
then we need to get the money directly
to local businesses and the way to do
that would be to establish regional
offices throughout sub-saharan Africa so
the country specific some region
specific offices would compete for
allocations of money based on reforms
money would be given directly to local
businesses through local business people
through private equity through US
business aid and when that money is
repaid it can either be given to
governments if that's the goal or given
directly in some recycling to other
businesses the marshall plan offers us a
way to do that there are countries in
sub-saharan Africa that are already
making good progress along these lines
Rwanda comes to mind is a great example
the World Bank actually tries to measure
the ease of doing business in a country
so called doing business indicators
rwanda has actually done very well at
this in the past couple of years moving
up 60 notches so there are some
countries already doing this
I think so a lot of the corruption that
arises in the present aid system is
because so much of aid flows go directly
through government organizations highly
concentrated payments that are prone to
corruption direct lending to individual
businesses yes there will be some
corruption yes there will be some
leakage is nothing is perfect but I
think it will be a lot less than we see
in the current system and you're
building a constituency of small and
medium sized business people with inner
powerful advocates against grouchy
well the Millennium Challenge account
started from a simple premise from
economic research in the past 10 or 20
years that there are some institutional
changes that lead to growth for example
having an independent judiciary
enforcement of simple debt contracts and
the rule of law institutional things
that make it easier for a business
person to operate over somebody can lend
you money and get paid back so the idea
the Millennium Challenge account was
let's take a pot of money and go to
countries receiving a is if you'd like
additional money you need to make these
institutional changes and that's a very
good idea except I think that too much
of the money was going directly to
government so missing the point about
how to directly get money in the hands
of the small business medium-sized
business sector so what I propose any
aid trap is to take essentially the idea
of the Millennium Challenge account a
step further why don't we go directly to
the local businesses having established
institutional forms
I'm fascinated by China's goals in
Africa it's essentially in our modern
time a version of what was the big game
a century or so ago of intrigue of
domination and I think what China has
done is made a bargain that is almost
colonial we will give you large amounts
of a ten-million-dollar promise from
China but an exchange we're interested
principally in locking up resources that
help us the Chinese in our growth very
little effort to promote african
business now I think for the u.s.
there's a double win here possible one
is to say look in terms of the economics
if you want growth in sub-saharan Africa
it's not going to be with special deals
with China it will be with invigorates
local business and second what better
foil for the u.s. to be the giver that
says no we're about local African
business we're not about taking
resources I think that's a real room for
us
I think that they're obviously the
Congress has many priorities at the
moment and this probably isn't the cop
one two or three but I do think there's
interest in both the Congress and the
administration for the simple reason
that I think President Obama would like
to take bold action here I think he
believes it's an imperative and I share
that view but he's shackled a bit by the
fact that you guys really can't spend
the amount of money that many advocates
are talking about this is an alternative
view for him if he didn't do this i'm
not sure what he would
sure well outside of Africa the two
growth miracles of the very recent
couple of decades have been India and
China both of those miracles have
involved opening and the very
significant growth of domestic business
so much like broke miracles we've seen
for centuries in Africa today in
sub-saharan Africa two countries in
recent years have done extraordinarily
well and moving up in the doing business
indicators a one is Rwanda and the
others Mauritius in both cases it's been
leaders that have been very focused on
the business sector both in courting
multinational investment but also
importantly encouraging local business
so this has been done I think it would
be a good idea for example for the World
Bank to take small groups of African
countries may be starting with co mesa
and eastern and southern Africa bring
together the best practices and try to
encourage this pro-business attitude